[Music]  what do i know that you need so bad  that's why you're here  to find out  [Music]  you're not crazy you never have been  do you find yourself drawn to places  you've never been  the visions you've had your entire life  aren't hallucinations  they're memories they're talking about  reincarnation the legend never dies  we call ourselves the infinite we  remember skills from  all our past lives it takes 10  000 hours to master  what do i know that you need so bad  that's why you're here to find out  we have fought one another for centuries  but you can't stop what's coming the end  of all things  is he blocked well well well we're gonna  have to reset your memory  you gonna drown me i gotta think about  drowning which is i don't like it  you know what man i like you this time  around shut up and turn it on  [Music]  there's still time time  no more time  the legend never dies  [Music]  you